hello everybody markiplier here along  with Bobby all what hey you know what  would be the worst thing ever  if chickens rained from the sky like  that one times not gonna happen  creepers would be bad chickens like a  deal shut up I didn't say anything  I now have five of my own death  certificates are suppliers death  certificate by Latin goddess it's  because all the ladies want zombie  please write in the comments ladies  about how much you think Bobby Moore is  like the sexiest guy oh no I can't kill  you because we're married  wait come kill mark dick Latins not here  Troy divorce /join divorce everybody  markiplier here along with Bob Oh what  right into the patient's face okay I  think it's me operating a part  shut up nurse are you serious but what  do you mean I mean you clearly know more  powerful spells than that